welcome welcome welcome on this
dreary dreary fall night here in uh in
Manhattan the Upper West Side of
Manhattan it's great to be here not many
people know this but uh since this is a
technology event and we'll be talking
about science and evolving technology
the Upper West Side of Manhattan is
still the largest concentration of
rotary phones left on planet Earth yes
how many of you have a rotary phone here
ah 30 people over there rais their hands
that's so we're here to discuss um
Walter isaacson's book The innovators
and before I introduce Walter I want to
talk about a couple of things do you all
have H first moments with computers what
was your first computer just call it out
1620 what what was it Sinclair Sinclair
that's great that is a good one
what what say compack okay what else
Macintosh okay yeah that's late in the
game but we love you we love Sinclair
yes yes there you go anybody anybody
batch process in college on an IBM 370
there we go yep carry those cards around
you know back then when you use
computers and had to haul those cards
from your dorm to the computer center
you did not look cool no no you did not
look like a hot shot like Steve Jobs uh
anybody Ed time sharing anybody remember
an audio coupler yep anybody play Gunner
on a computer time sharing terminal uh
Gunner was this great game that I played
in my calculous class in the 70s and
sixth grade and it you you put the phone
on the coupler you you dialed into a
time share uh computer system and Gunner
was this really silly game which
basically was a graphic reenactment on a
printer uh that a teletype printer at
that so it wasn't terribly Advanced of
essentially quadratic equ equations and
um uh you know limits and you know
equations for parabolas that sort of
thing and so you basically do art
artillery uh and you type in your
coordinates to the person who is playing
you at some college maybe across town
and the computer would
go
and then it would start
printing another
Dot and it would gradually make the
parabola and when the parabola would
come
down it would ding if you hit and if you
didn't
hit and I know that sounds very
primitive it sounds a little bit like
making you know a sule with Arro heads
but um but but we were fascinated this
was so this was so great this was like
what's going to happen what and we could
have calculated what would have happened
in our Calculus class but just the fact
that a machine was doing it was so
absolutely thrilling and this was the
moment that computers were changing they
were going from being big defense
contractor items that were used to
direct weapons and of course a lot of
the technology that I was using in the
1970s was developed to win World War II
and part of what wal is going to be
talking about out here is Alan touring
and and some of the individuals vanar
Bush who was at MIT who was part of the
MIT war effort that original technology
really became the basis for what we use
in our uh uh home computers today here's
something that came about in um the uh
the early 60s because in many ways
Computing is a fusion of two things that
are very very well-known um one of
course mathematics and uh and and and
and and computers themselves but the
second thing is animation what you can
see here this is space War uh a computer
game very rudimentary computer game um
but what happens in space war is that
your mind creates a world out of that
bunch of dots which are represented in a
very very simple mathematical set in the
computer's memory and all of a sudden
you can pretend that you're in a
spaceship and so the development of
computer gaming really fused the power
of the mind's ability to suspend
disbelief and to believe that that
character is real believe that that's
actually a dinosaur believe that Mario
is your neighbor um for instance all of
this power fused together it's not just
one brain that's working to make space
War a great video game it's two brains
the brain of the user and the Brain
inside the computer and so that in many
ways is the cultural story that's told
in the uh innovator and in in the
innovators and one of the great things
about this book and we're going to
interrogate Walter all about it is that
the computers were developed along the
same time as a whole culture was
emerging from the 60s the um you know
free love and and drug culture that you
know very very uh sort of primitively
describes what was going on but in fact
uh the whole earth catalog is something
that came directly out of the
counterculture movement and what the
whole earth catalog is about and I don't
know if you can see it whole earth
catalog is what it says but the subtitle
is access to tools and the idea that
individual humans could have access to
tools and that those tools could be used
to create things is really a part of the
Confluence of culture and technology
that becomes the experience that we're
living today and becomes The Narrative
of the innovators add to that characters
like um well does anyone recognize this
bus here oh you used to own it no no no
no no no this is the Mary prankster bus
and how many people know who the mar
pranksters were yeah there we go Ken key
and the marry pranksters and the
Grateful Dead who took a lot of LSD uh
and roamed that's Ken key right there
and Ken key of course wrote one floow of
the Cougar's Nest which was you know
about an a a mental uh Asylum for people
with mental difficulties and it really
sort of made the point that in many ways
Walter makes again and again in this
book of of the innovators that there's a
certain kind of fringing about the
mentality of people who were willing to
take the risks to innovate and key the
merry pranksters The Grateful Dead's
notion of improvisation really caught
the attention of Steve Jobs up at Reed
College where he was experimenting right
isn't that the word with drugs
experimenting it was a class he was
taking up there at Reed College um but
the counterculture fuses with the
technology culture fuses with a sense of
individuality and Democracy in America
so in many many ways America is the
petri dish for all these things coming
together and it's there's such an
excitement about how technology the
military-industrial complex that wins
the war fused with the Democracy
movement of the whole earth catalog and
and uh The Counter Culture in America is
is this beautiful beautiful story that's
transformed the culture of the world and
that's where I want to begin uh tonight
let me just tell you before before we uh
begin that this is my uh first computer
here can Josh can you you put up my my
uh I'll start crying when I see you
I I love that
hp41c you know they took one of those up
on the space shuttle when it first
launched and and now the amount of
computing that's required to operate a
space the space station is you know by a
factor of a thousand bigger than that
but but originally that was the only
computer that they could use in the
space program to calculate re-entry
uh uh trajectories and anything heavier
than that couldn't have made it up into
space and it was all there on that
programmable computer that I used to
actually program the timing that was
left on the All Things Considered
newscast when I was a newscaster at all
things considered and I would sit there
and I made this program and my assistant
producer was saying what what what is
this what is and we would type in the
times of each of the stories that we
were doing and I would know okay great
we're right at five minutes we can go
and uh it was just my if i' started a
company maybe I'd be not up here
introducing Walter Ison but uh but
that's neither here or there please
welcome with us tonight president and
CEO of the Aspen Institute previously
the chairman of CNN and editor of Time
Magazine he's the bestselling author of
the biography of Steve Jobs his most
recent book The innovators how a group
of hackers Geniuses and Geeks created
the digital Revolution is already a
bestseller it'll be number three on the
New York Times bestseller list it's a
nominee for the national book award
please welcome Walter Isaacson
who if you read this book
closely you will realize that despite
his background as a Harvard educated
sort of uh you know academic Brahman
straight A student brilliant journalist
and writer what he really wanted to do
was run away from home and join this
circus absolutely all right Walter it's
great to see cool great and I really
love the way you brought in video games
because that's something people haven't
talked enough about the book but video
games are totally part of that
excitement well uh first of all what was
your first computer my first computer
was an Osborne you know the one that you
got to pull up that Adam Osborne made
and then a kpro I guess a kpro was right
before that then the Osborne and then
finally a compact and uh Rosen who lives
right down the street here was then
chairman of compac and he he was a
friend of my fathers they grew up in New
Orleans and I remember calling him one
saying I can't get it to you know you
had to do this floppy disc and he came
over and actually put in one of the
first hard drives with a screwdriver and
those were the days which we don't have
anymore when you could actually open up
your computer you could jack in you
could put things in the circuit the way
wnc wanted nowadays everything's so
sealed that you're a little bit
intimidated used to be able to do with
Chevy as well but yeah right yeah yeah
exactly um did you ever build did you
ever build I did a heath kit I did a and
it did not work but I did a heath K ham
radio that did work and what were you
trying to to what was your interest was
it was it a scientific interest was it a
hobbyist interest hobbyist I mean you
you people come at it from different
ways you know if you're Brian Green you
come at it because you want to know
what's happening on the surface state of
a a semiconductor of silicon and how are
those electrons dancing me you know I
wanted to solder things and you know and
there was a geek hobbyist culture I'm
not sure you mentioned when you're
talking about all the tribes but one of
the tribes is a you know the Teenagers
Who Loved building ham radio yeah I was
one of those yeah that was5 John Thomas
Peter my I had a heath kit shortwave
radio yeah and I do think that that's
something that almost all the innovators
in this book I mean from lick ligher to
you know uh Bob noise to uh you know all
the great people in this book they
tended to fiddle in the basement you
know and and and build things and I
worry about the lack of tinkering and
hobbyists um today but maybe you know we
shouldn't worry well we'll get to that
let's talk first about the culture of
these various tribes because I think
what is fascinating about this book is
that it really describes the tribes very
very well and you've got in the very
very beginning in the 19th century the
the tribe of of of calculators of of
people who are trying to view in a
completely abstract way because there
weren't any tools around at the time and
Charles babage tried to create them and
the British government didn't end up
funding much of what he did although he
did enough to make the very first
sequester and you know it's like all
sequesters it's destroy science yeah and
and the Brits were much more interested
in hunting for elephants and rivers in
Africa than they were in making
computers that's right so what what did
it take to be someone like aah Lovel who
discovered that calculating was not
simply equations but was algorithms a
set of instructions I think that the
main thing she had in a larger sense was
the ability to connect the Arts to The
Sciences you know what we do here on
this stage all the time the humanities
to engineering as you know her father
Lord Byron the poet was a lite and I
mean that literally because the only
speech he gives in the House of Lords is
defending the followers of Ned lud who
are smashing the mechanical Looms in
England thinking it's going to put
Weavers out of work uh but aah went on a
trip to the Midlands saw the mechanical
Loom saw the way Punch Cards were
instructing the Looms to do beautiful
patterns and Chi was friends with babage
as you said and he was making his
calculating machine doing numbers and
she realized that the punch cards can
make it so as she put it because she
publishes which is unusual for a woman
in the uh 1830s to publish a scientific
paper on babbage's machine saying that
because of the punch cards and other
things it can do anything that can be
notated in symbols not just numbers but
it can do words it can do it can weave
tapestries as beautiful as the jacard
loom she writes and it could even make
music something that would have cause
Lord Byron to Flinch the no but what
she's seeing there is exactly what John
Von noyman sees the general purpose
computer and Allan touring sees it that
that there is that symbols are agnostic
they don't they don't depend on violins
they don't depend on typewriters they
don't depend on the machines that make
them symbols have a life of their own
and you can manipulate them logically
and then the cool thing that comes along
which is not obviously Ada but comes
along a hundred years later is people
like Claude Shannon and others who take
Boolean algebra which was you know
devised around the time of adal Love
lace and says okay we can use circuits
to do onoff switches that can do the
logic basically and that's when all of
of a sudden machines seem to think one
of the things that a says at the end of
her notes on the analytical engine
machines will do everything they'll do
music they do this that and the other
and then she says but they will never
think they will never originate thought
they will never be an imaginative it'll
take the human partnership with the
machine to originate thought and that's
what Allan touring a 100 years later
calls lady love LA's objection and says
how would we know that and he comes you
all will see the movie in about three or
four weeks I'm sure called the imitation
game which is about touring doing it and
he devises what he calls the imitation
game we call the touring test where he
says how would we know a machine can't
think what if what if we can't tell a
machine apart from a human in its
answers then there's no reason to say
the machine's not thinking what kind of
a character is touring and compare him
to the people who were more involved in
the building of the machines that could
do what touring imagined would be the
test of intelligence
yeah touring was very much of a theorist
and a mathematician AER and a loner and
uh homosexual at a time when if you're
in the MI6 government service trying to
break the German Enigma codes in England
coming out of the Victorian era is not
that easy to be but he was also not
ashamed of being homosexual so it's a
very complicated thing uh but the main
thing is he comes up with the notion of
the universal Computing machine
something that can do any form of L I
mean anything that any machine could do
you know a universal machine can do that
type of logic and so that becomes a
foundation for van noyman and others who
turn it into an architecture for
computers but one of the things that
struck me just at that point in the book
although Steve Jobs had turned me on to
the idea earlier and it began to sink in
was it isn't just the Visionary who does
something you have to have a team that
then starts to implement it and so so uh
touring is this great logical
theoretician but because it's wartime
and they got to break the German codes
he's sewn in with Tommy flowers who
worked for the phone company in Britain
and knew how how vacuum tubes or valves
as they call them in England how vacuum
tubes work and you know there are
mechanics and there's people who do
cross people get hired at blessy Park by
doing the telegraph Crossroad puzzle
really well so you have all sorts of
interesting people working on the teams
and the desperation to win the war meant
that the rule book of crossword puzzles
aren't anything that we need for
National Security all that had to be
thrown out and and there had to be a
real sort of stepping back from actually
there's a where there isn't a stepping
back where the hierarchy of the British
intelligence is having trouble figuring
out how to deal with this guy touring
and his crowd and touring writes a
letter to Winston Churchill who reads it
and calls off the Dilly Knox and the
people running MI6 and says let these
people break the code there's a parallel
story that takes place in the United
States less tragic than touring but what
was the tension like in the United
States between by the way should we get
to the tra do people know the tragic
yeah let's why don't you go ahead well
um I touring as I said was gay and he
finally gets I you know by the 50s gets
arrested for gross and decency um and so
he sentenced as if he were a machine to
undertake hormone treatment so he will
not commit homosexual act and gross
indecency at this time what year uh I
think we're talking 1949 50 or so yeah
right that would be on basic cable to
yeah right right right exactly uh so you
know and he submits to all of this but
then at the end and he takes an apple
dips it in Cyanide and bites into the
apple and commits suicide because of
this issue and in some ways when you're
saying when he's arguing that machines
are no different from humans will
replicate the human mind in a machine in
some way Allan touring and his life
that's not something a machine would
have done and his life is almost a
Counterpoint to the notion that the
human and the Machine are
indistinguishable I mean he's he's
really sending a message like LEL did um
solve this problem I can't I'm out now
there's also something extraordinarily
symbolic about the way he commits
suicide there's a Biblical Dimension but
then there's also Newton and Snow White
CU he loved the way Snow White di the
apple and years ago my daughter said to
me taking a walk she said you know the
Apple logo is an homage to touring a
bite out of the Apple so I go no I
didn't know that now with all the
certitude of a 15-year-old she told me
you know of course that's right that was
defense against the Beatles and this was
right before I was doing um uh the Steve
Jobs book but he and I had been in
contact and he was a person who emailed
you back right away if he wanted to or
didn't email you back at all I mean if
you you didn't get an answer in about a
minute he was going to ignore you so I'm
walking across you know with Betsy and I
type in you know Steve at Apple duck and
I said is that true was she and he
answered me right away he said no I
sometimes wish I could say it was true I
wish we had thought of that it is a
really cool story but when we did the
logo we hadn't thought of that yet so
proving that 15y olds can be wrong and
Steve Jobs can even admit mistakes
15-year-olds can invent urban legends
exactly that's great um all right so um
what is the team in the United States
that invents the computer and there were
many teams around the world but what is
the team that you focus on and what was
the tension between throwing out the
rule book and and uh really sticking to
some sort of very linear tradition in
the military hierarchy yeah well
actually there's two places you could
say the computer was invented in the
United States we biographers know that
we distort history a little bit we give
a little too much credit to the lone
inventor who in the basement or the
garage comes up with a light bulb moment
and Innovation occurs and if you're a
romantic historian or if you're Jane
Smiley the novelist or somebody like
that you pick out John Vincent at an ass
off who at Iowa State University makes a
ircuit a electronic logical circuit and
is able to invent the first electronic
circuit board now he's a loner and so
it's kind of romantic has one graduat
but no team around him so he can't
really get it working he can't get the
punch card burnner to work and when he
goes into the Navy they don't even know
what this contraption is he's been
building and they dismantle and throw it
away you have another team that's just
the opposite led by John Mockley John
Mockley was one of these people who
loves being at places like this he loved
wood panel explorers clubs and Carnegie
institutes and Smith zians and science
festivals and historical societies he
was part of that British American Cadre
of people who loves sharing science he
goes all over the place CU he wants to
build a computer and he's like a
bumblebee he picks up pollen in places
and cross pollinates things so he goes
to the 1939 World's Fair and sees what
they're doing he goes to Dartmouth with
this Bell Labs has a sbit machine he
goes to Harvard and MIT where Vana bush
had done a non digital an analog machine
so he picks up all these things and he
finally hears this guy in Iowa State he
actually runs into him in Philadelphia
and for four days he drives to Iowa
state with his kid just so he can see
the computer so then he comes back to
pen and unlike ad anass off he builds a
team and that's what I was talking about
earlier you know the building of the
team is the important thing he he gets
preser eard who uh is a great engineer
he gets you know mechanics people with
grease under their fingernails he has 70
people they're building this room size
thing and he gets about 70 women phds in
math who are doing the calculations he
picks six of them to secretly get
training at Aberdine proving uh Proving
Ground to reprogram the computer they
understand the in of the computer when
John V noyman comes from Los alus and
needs to have the machine not do
ballistic missile trajectories but to do
a test of a hydrogen type bomb uh the is
the women who reprogram it what is it
intuitively about this team of women
that that understands programming and
these sets of instructions and how
interchangeable they are any thoughts on
that yeah I mean women have
unfortunately been written out of the
history of computing a little bit more
than they should have been and these
women are not as well known as they
should be but more women got p phds in
math in the 1930s then in the 50s or the
60s it was before women had been told by
our friends that they didn't know how to
do math or something and so women were
great
mathematicians and they also were more
collaborative I don't mean to get into a
gender thing of but but they all worked
together and so they did open source of
cobalt all these programming languages
Hopper Grace Hopper is working what they
ask for directions right right I'm
trying very hard not to step in any
landmines but you're allowed to yeah
um but here's another one which is boys
with their toys you think the hardware
is the cool thing you know they're like
me they like soldering things and they
they think the hardware is a big thing
and figuring out how to program it you
know that's menial the women can do that
they don't realize that after a while
eniac and univac and Honeywell and sper
Rand and whatever types of computers are
those are going to be interchangeable
it's the actual programming language
that's going to to be the real value you
don't particularly care which piece of
Hardware you're using so the women did
the programming back then both
Lieutenant Grace Hopper at Harvard doing
it with um Howard Aken on the mark one
and then the Six Women of eniac led by
Jean Jennings and uh Jennings and Hopper
are a fascinating story yeah they really
are you know one of the things I'll give
a thing about Jennings that struck me
Jean Jennings is from Atlantis Grove
Missouri a town of like 108 she's one of
seven kids or kids or whatever Poor Farm
family who really loved education so she
decided she wants to be a mathematician
she couldn't decide between journalism
and math and she made the right choice
became a mathematician and went to
Northwest Missouri State College for $78
a year and so she became and then on her
last month there she sees an ad that
says come to Philadelphia we need women
mathematicians to work in aniac there
she is y so um illegal to run that that
ad today we need it actually said it
says uh women wanted you know because it
was making fun of the men wanted sort of
thing but most this was 44 men were off
of War so she gets on the train at
midnight from Atlantis Grove and arrives
in Philadelphia 40 hours later has the
job but I did look up
Northwest um Missouri state is now
$14,000 a year we're going to lose a
generation of people who could go to
college with $78 a year and become the
Pioneer program of her
generation so uh these women not Rosie
the riveters but Rosie the coders um
begin to develop enough programs that
the thought begins to converge now that
that machines are interchangeable that
the software can evolve to more
sophisticated uh capabilities and that
the the pure Hardware is not necessarily
the measure of what these things can do
it's a it's a is a partnership between
more sophisticated software and more
capacity Hardware right because at first
these machines are built for special
purposes Colossus which is the one that
Tommy flowers and Alan touring work on
at Bletchley Park is there just to break
the German code likewise the eniac which
you saw back there the women programming
it um that was mainly done for ballistic
missile artillery tables but they
discover oh the war is ending and we
needed to do Adam B test and sonar and
you know sonic waves and everything else
so it's the first one that's really
reprogrammable and then John Von noyman
comes along and says we can store the
programs in the memory of the machine
and that's when you really get a real
computer so I think of eniac is the
first real computer because it's
programmable it's general purpose and
it's really cool we don't have time to
go into it but the story of how memory
is developed and the engineering that
goes into the creation of memory and the
various ways that were tried that worked
and some that didn't work how clever
they were how amazing they were and how
it informed our understanding of what
memory actually is shortterm long-term
readon is a great great story it's in
this book there's other uh uh treatments
of that particular story but let's
launch ahead to really when the
convergence becomes Complete because
suddenly with solid state electronics
and uh the ability to kind of home
engineer enough computer capability to
begin to program on your own suddenly
we're in the realm of gates and jobs and
the Apple gang well you talked about I
think you know I was listening from the
back uh the sort of that cultural Brew
in the early
1970s and you know you have everybody
from the hippies to the anti-war
protesters to the hobbyists and hackers
and electronic Geeks and stuff like that
so uh what happens around in the early
1970s is the hobbyist comes first Ed
Roberts creates the alter which does
almost absolutely nothing it just has a
few lights it blinks and a few switches
and you can do it uh but since it all
comes back to good product launches he
gets himself on the cover of popular
electronics and and sends the AL on the
road to The Homebrew Computer Club which
is where all these you know hackers and
Geeks and they all coming together in
the early' 70s now a couple things
happen it's on the cover of popular
elonics and this guy Bill Gates who's a
sophomore at Harvard has convinced this
friend of his Paul Allen to drop out of
school and move to Boston for no
apparent reason because he's you know
and Paul Allen in that out of town news
stand right in Harvard Square sees po it
says the AL T grabs a copy pays 75 cents
and runs The Courier house where Bill
Gates is living and plops it down and
says this is happening without us and
Gates just starts rocking as he used to
do or still does probably and says oh my
God and it's exam period and he blows
off all four of his exams and they just
sit there on a defense department paid
for computer at the aen computer lab
where Grace Hopper and Howard had worked
and they code um a basic for the alt and
let's let's um step back for a moment
and just give you a sense of the
primitiveness of this uh computer the
alter there were Heath there were Heath
kits that you could buy in the h catalog
I believe there were Sinclair's you
could buy in the whole earth catalog at
the time so so this this culture was
able to um really offer to people out
there stuff that uh they could use to
really launch Into The Ether the
Christopher Columbus's of uh programming
and what computers could actually mean
uh how many of you are Beatles fans yep
okay you know the song Fool on the Hill
m sing along with me all right day after
day blown on a hill the man with a
foolish grin is keeping perfectly still
this is alter's rendition Steve dumpier
first meeting of the Homebrew Computer
Club they get an Al they start playing
with it and he realizes because it
interferes with radio signals on his uh
little radio he can tell the altar to
make music adah Love LA's vision is you
know captured there can we hear that
again Josh let's let's hear if ad would
really have loved
this she would have she would
have the AL was
191 no no
Gates uh I think it's um January 73 the
cover of popular electronics and so it
was December of 70 to I think maybe a
year off so early 70s is this the
machine that Gates takes home to or
something like it that he takes home to
begin to develop b yeah so they develop
this is it I mean the original Al and um
Gates sits there at Harvard and they do
basic uh since Gates can't even shave
yet I mean he's you know he's like looks
like a Cub Scout uh they send Paul who
actually has sideburns at that point to
fly to Albuquerque to make the sale of
basic for the AL and so that's where
that Zuckerberg didn't have that problem
no no no uh but what happens is I say
they take the alter on the road they
bring it to the Homebrew Computer Club
do Steve dumpier who's you know one of
these hippie Geeks says okay I can make
it do Fool on the Hill but they also
watch it do basic and there's a tape you
know a software a you know tape to doing
basic and they copy it and they make you
know 70 copies and give it away for free
stealing and to use Bill Gates's word
his software program because this is
where you get the tension between
software wanting to be free and that
open source Thing versus for the first
time somebody says because the women who
did Cobalt didn't do this he says Paul
Allen and Bill Gates doing business as
micro Dash soft and they wanted to be
able to have a copyright on it or and um
intellectual property versus open source
right and you have his famous letter to
The Homebrew Computer Club say what
you're doing is theft um but but also at
that meeting I mean this is like huge
it's a great movie scene if anybody
wants to make a movie of this book
because sitting there is Steve wnc who
thinks personal computers are stupid he
he's building terminals that connect to
main frames but then he looks at this
and he looks at the specs for the Intel
8088 which is what allowed this to
happen he says I can make something
better I can make it that connects to a
monitor so he does and he does the specs
for it and he brings it to the next
meeting of the home broking PL with a TV
that's carried by his friend from down
the street Steve Jobs and W hands out
for free to every because you know he's
kind of he communal he read the whole
earth catalog once too often and he's
like giving away the Apple the design
it's not named yet and finally Steve
Jobs after the second or third meeting
says wait a minute we can go to my
parents garage and make these things and
we can sell them and make money and
that's how apple is born so out of see
that prototype Josh again Apple computer
and uh I like that that retro look is
really nice I think that's yeah Steve
Jobs's design sense pre Johnny I was uh
yeah retro we didn't have the whiteness
of the iPod back then and so but we did
by the time he does the Apple 2 he
he and and the story of I really is the
story of beginning to think about
computers not as detached objects that
are independent of humans but as things
that can integrate even physically with
humans and the story of the mouse is the
story of the ways in which computers
suddenly began to integrate physically
with the with the The Poetry of the
human body become intimate and connected
to us and in the book I create two
strands of thought what I call the adal
love lace strand which is computers and
humans will become Partners we will work
together in an intimacy she says a
symbiosis like that the other strand is
the Allen touring strand which is we'll
have artificial intelligence machine
learning and they'll end up creating a
singularity and work without us and you
know have that sort of thing well you
know people keep and you'll have people
on the stage talking about the
singularity you know any decade you can
have people doing it well we haven't
gotten anywhere near there yet but what
we keep getting Leaps and Bounds is this
making the computer more intimate
creating the mouse adal love life would
love that this symbiosis putting it on
our wrists putting it on our glass I
just the guy somebody here I was get you
know help me figure out Google Glass
today from the Google uh site here and
it's like oh we may have a toy for you
later oh okay I I hope I hope an old
pong game because I'm well we have that
we definitely have that it's right but
anyway I just I mean without overdoing
it I think the intimacy that you've
talking about really makes it good
that's the first Mouse that's Doug
engelbart's Mouse uh Doug engelbart is
another unsung hero uh who's in this
book a lot he people like him and Allan
Kay who do the graphical unit user
interface at Xerox Park uh learn to make
it there's old Allen K learn to make it
so that these computers are friends
convivial they used words like that as
opposed to Singularity and they do it by
reversing the math in a sense what made
uh space war was the computer output
going to the screen in mathematical dots
what they did was that same signal can
come off a ball rolling around with a
sensor you send that into the computer
computer doesn't care what it is it it
says oh I I get it and can turn that
into directionality on a screen and boom
you you can go both directions and what
you have in Len K and others do it too
is a whole lot of things come together
that you don't think are that important
but they connect the art to the
technology you do that with something
called bit mapping which means every you
know when you and I were growing up and
talking about our kpros and stuff there
were those horrible phosphorous green
letters on dark screen and what the
computer would do to save power is to
generate a letter know to generate a V
and it be up there what Allan K Doug
inart and others figured out is that
every pixel on the screen can be turned
on and off or for that matter any color
if you have enough computing power by
this point Gordon moris told us it will
double every 18 months or so so they
create with the mouse bit mapping
graphical user interfaces and Steve Jobs
who has dropped out of college and
everything else the one course he really
loves and he takes even though he's not
actually enrolled in college is
calligraphy so the first thing he does
when he sees bit mapping he says I can
make it do beautiful fonts everybody
else is saying who cares about beauty
beautiful fonts Steve's great insight
was Beauty matters and fonts is a hard
problem yeah making fonts is a hard
problem and if you can solve fonts you
can basically create any kind of
graphical representation the amazing
thing that is almost the exuberation of
the personal computer is when he unveils
the Macintosh he's taken from Xerox Park
the notional graph and he pulls the bag
out from over it and it starts writing
hello I'm Macintosh in script like that
and people gas
it's cool and it's part of this sort of
convergence of our animation sense that
we will suspend disbelief once it does
that that's a human talking to us that's
a creature that's a being that's not a
machine so much convivial it's conv
personal it's personal if you have to
look at another trajectory of the
digital age it gets more everything gets
more and more personal you put it in
your pocket by the end or you put it on
your wrist and you talked about to the
video games which are very because they
come along at the same time you know
you're doing space war and they're doing
the same time that lick lier jcr
licklider is another amazing character
is doing an air defense system and so
they have to have really fast
interactive Computing so that notion
that it's fun it's interactive it's very
graphical and it responds to you comes
up from everything from the consoles
that the uh air defense jockeys had to
use at the sage system and they're doing
it at MIT and all and so the people at
MIT and the tech model Railway Club are
also saying okay and we can make space
War out of it and it it all comes
together we can make it fun and it's it
has a personality and job sort of really
put all that and here's an important
point I mean one reason I wrote this
book is nowadays half the people not
people would come to this group half the
people in this world are intimidated by
technology they you think it's you think
it's still
half intimidated yeah I think people
have no clue
like what bit mapping is and why that's
a really cool thing or how you have a
logical circuit that tells something to
be a graphical display or how a circuit
works or what a transistor is and why a
microchip is just transistors edged on a
chip and that makes us you talked about
convivial and personal and feeling
comfortable understanding that real
people like lick lier and Allan Kay and
Steve Jobs and W kind of did this and
how they did it it I think makes us feel
less alienated from our technology but
do we need to understand about photons
to be lighting decorators in our own
house and do you need to understand she
Walks in Beauty like the night you know
one of adah's Daddy's lines um no but
I've heard Brian Green talk about this
if you want to just be a joyous human
being you kind of want to know what a
line of poetry means how a photon works
even try to perhaps grapple with uh why
quantum mechanics makes the surface
state of a semiconductor a dance of
electrons that can be
manipulated that's beautiful almost as
beautiful as uh some of Lord Byron's
poems well as a Storyteller you
certainly have a role to play in sort of
Distributing the sense of wonder and
curiosity about uh technology but I I
sense that you're really uh stalling
Walter and we need to play Pong now all
right when did you first play Pong I'm
not going to tell
you there it
is okay uh let's start here we go all
right there's a
ball where's the ball oh there you got
it oh yes I didn't have to do
anything uh with Alco oh shoot when Al
alorn did this the best shoot the best
turn those lights down you guys it's
favoring him oh you want him to win all
the best thing he did was that sound of
the pong boy I'm really getting bad at I
used to be good I think you need I think
you needed to be slightly stoned to play
this game there I
go I I asked you if you wanted to get
high
back so uh figuring out the electronics
of just making it go F just play I'm
trying to distract you I'm I'm
down oh o o that wouldn't that was
pretty bad a man uh oh you're catching
up now you say well you catch up when we
serve we're all oh see see I mean I'm
just I'm helping him went there we
go oh trick
shot you're done you're
done
y yeah that was a good one and now I get
to serve one more shot yeah hey one more
I got to catch up don't don't quit now
uh oh this is it this is
it he also hey okay we'll stop there he
also made it so that if you thank
you we we practice a lot so we would tie
at the end uh and there's no overtime in
a regular season pong game but um I to
renew my so that wherever you hit on it
it would go directly back if you hit in
the middle but it goes off at an angle
so it was you know it was really cool
but the other thing they learned at
Atari and Steve Jobs worked the night
shift at Atari this B's group yeah Nolan
Bushnell owns it Al alorn is the
engineer of that Steve Jobs come in
comes in and he had just um dropped out
of college and gone to India and found
his Guru so he comes back and he eats
only vegetables but no grain no meat
fruits and vegetables fruitarian diet
and he tells Al Al corn uh if you have
this diet you don't have to use
deodorant and alorn told me that was a
mistaken Theory so I put him on the
night shift
so so he and W are working at the night
shift and they one of the first things
they do is a single player version of
pong called breakout and um I you know I
asked Steve what did you learn you know
from video games besides the Beauty and
the pixel all that sort of thing he said
you really have to keep it simple uh
space War when they first do it at Atari
they take the space war game from MIT
and it has you know in gravity there's
no space you have to use it there's like
eight instructions in that game there
was just one instruction which was
avoid uh Missing ball for high score
which is a slightly garbled sentence but
a stone freshman can figure it out after
midnight you know you don't need a
manual yeah yeah let's uh shift to the
internet part of the innovation of the
internet itself comes from figuring out
how to take data and transmit it and in
the same way that bit mapping is the key
insight to creating Graphics that are uh
both uh flexible and also beautiful uh
uh packet uh transmission is the key
insight to uh transmitting data because
these the sort of initial notion would
be the mail where you oh you take the
message you put it into a box and then
you send the box and of course messages
are going to be different sizes and all
the boxes will be different sizes and
there's all sorts of complexity
associated with that just work at UPS
and you understand the problems there um
but packet delivery was really something
amazing and had a difficult sell in in
the beginning absolutely and packet
switching breaks it into just a small
little things puts a you know a
very small finite block puts a header on
it breaks up the entire message uh as if
you took a whole long letter and put it
into 50 postcards and let them each
follow a different route with
instructions on how to reassemble
package delivery is like will you stand
up please yes uh oh all right stand
right up here on the stage uh oh all
right so let's say we're going to send
him yeah through the internet right what
we would do is basically we'd saw off
his hand and a piece of his arm and his
shoulder and his head and his foot and
maybe the other arm all into little
packets and on those packets would be
the name of him right and uh the uh
place that it connects to those two
things plus whatever it is that's in
your hand arm shoulder head that we've
hacked off and so all the pieces would
come apart right they'd Zoom through
data I mean your hand would take a
different rout than your foot your head
would take a your your head might go a
little slower um possibly uh and and
then you'd be reassembled very very
quickly and the instructions for
reassembly is contained within each
individual packet yes and that has a
very important philosophical thing first
of all you can I assume sit right or you
can be teleported to wherever you're
going next thank you very much um don't
try that at home yeah I mean a couple
things that that that does you talk
about UPS or FedEx or for that matter
the phone company which keeps a circuit
open the entire time you're having a
conversation so that means there Central
hubs which means it can be controlled by
Authority it means you know somebody can
decide what goes through that Hub a
Comcast can be in charge of pack
whatever it may be but a packet switch
every single node has just as much
ability to store and forward a packet
and therefore if some node gets knocked
out or somebody does something and tries
to sensor things the internet routes
around it this has two functions one is
that Paul bar who is one of the founders
of packet switching out at ran
Corporation now there's Donald Davies in
England and then a few others he's doing
it to help survive a nuclear attack if
the Russians hit our communication
system he wants America to be able to
retaliate which is actually a good thing
because it prevents us from wanting to
do a first strike it makes us less hair
me you have to distribute the data it
means that you have to have no
centralized Hub that they're can attack
and if they hit 50 different places
they'll still you know those little
package will Scurry around the spider's
web and Route around it so that's the
reason he does it he explains it day the
Bell System and AT&T over and over again
they say it won't work they finally
bring him for four days of seminars they
bring 90 experts explaining to him why
instead of having a dedicated circuit
packet switching won't work and they say
do you understand this now and he goes
no and um he's right they're wrong which
is why the Bell System never built the
internet um but the really cool thing is
the people who did end up building it
the arpanet this is because it starts
off as a defense department project are
um the research centers that the defense
department is funding and being research
centers they delegate it to their
graduate students to figure out how to
do the
protocols The Graduate students are all
graduate students indefinitely because
they're avoiding the Vietnam War and so
they're staying in graduate school as
long as they can they AR trying to help
the Pentagon survive a nuclear attack
they want to build a system system that
can't be censored can't be controlled
can't have a top- down Authority so they
create this decentralized or distributed
system of the internet the cool thing is
I have a section in the book on was it
to help survive a nuclear attack and
half the people say no And so there's a
guy Steve lukich who was high up in the
Pentagon and funding this he finally
says to Steve Crocker who's one of the
young graduates you don't really know
because uh you on the bottom and I was
on top so I know why it was developed
and Crocker said no you don't really
know you were on the top I was on the
bottom so you have no clue which is the
perfect specification of and now that
DNA that the finger the sort of into the
genetic code is embed the notion of we
Route Around Authority and that uh
distributed system architecture also
creates the other huge advantage that a
packet switching system delivers and
that is scalability infinite scalability
without scalability everybody can be a
node on the internet right everybody can
be a node on on the internet everybody's
computer can be a part of the internet
and there's one little story and then I
want to invite our other guests up on
stage who have uh sort of direct
experience with exactly what we're
talking about here um there are a few
people who object to allowing their
computers to be used to basically be
hijacked little sort of bit packages for
this distributed system can you describe
that yeah you know I think which maybe
referring to is I wrestled with the fact
that the people who invented the
personal computer and first had it the
hobbyists the hackers the phone freakers
um they really wanted something personal
Allen K even at xerx Park you could take
it out to the woods it was a personal
creativity device so the personal
computer arising in the 70s is arising
at the same time as the arpanet and then
the arpanet there's other networks that
come along so they have to inter Network
them which is why we get the phrase
internet um but they're separate because
the people are using the internet you
know want to sort of share each other's
computers and the people who creating a
personal computer want to go off in the
woods and you know do whatever they do
with computers um wow that like a book
it takes a while in fact I didn't get
this at first I was going to do this as
a history of the internet and it was gay
when I interviewed him who said no you
don't get it in the 70s is was where all
of a sudden the networking and the
personal computer come together in
modems online services and that is like
the steam engine coming together with
mechanical processes to create the
Industrial Revolution it's that
combustible combination that creates a
digital Revolution produces the
railroads yeah exactly that yeah but
what were you you may have been
referring to something else on the
personal computer oh Marvin Minsky
oh yeah MIT he thought it was we're
using our computer we got all of our
computers you know oh that's when the
researchers did not want to have it the
Pentagon was funding you know Marvin
Minsky all these research centers he was
at MIT he's part of the artificial
intelligence crowd in fact he comes up
with the concept of artificial
intelligence in the 50s uh but he
doesn't want his computers to be shared
because he's into this our computers you
know as opposed to making them in
connected to us and the Pentagon this
isn't the good old days well the
Pentagon is actually doing some good
stuff uh it's you know the Eisenhower
years are particularly good but they
kind of force people to share to
collaborate and they say okay you will
get no more funding unless you become
part of this collaborative system any
parent of a three-year-old can relate to
that right right bribe them and they
will share yeah it's true of MIT
professors and teenagers exactly all
right um the we're going to continue all
of these themes and and we're going to
continue talking to Walter but part of
what's great about this program is
really what we want to do is extend the
story and bring some uh other characters
in who have really lived this in a way
that two journalists up here really
haven't um our next guest is at the
crosssection of the digital Revolution
helping to build the internet pre and
post Timothy burner Lee a character who
figures prominently in the internet and
uh then moves to creating things using
digital technology she's currently the
CEO of MakerBot a global leader in 3D
printing please welcome Jenny
[Applause]
L thank you also with us is someone who
can give us a real life view of the
startup of a technology company she
doesn't work in a garage at this point
but she probably has seen the inside of
a a garage thinking of ideas for her new
company exactly what she's doing now is
creating a new company the CEO and
founder of the new career platform the
muse.com she's a top finalist in the
Wall Street Journal startup of the Year
competition please welcome Katherine
[Applause]
minu now not only do you see the gender
split here you see the generational
split here your first computer trash 80
trash 80 that was you used those as a
journal yeah you you you're you were
there at the beginning yeah trash IDs
was a Tandy yeah R Radio Shack radio
radio right and did you use it as a
journalist or as a fun person it at work
work uh yeah to to make our mailing
mailing list at the work did you have to
carry all those adapters and the printer
around with it and the no I did that
with my compact uh you know portable the
one one sort of like size of a sewing
machine I used to take that out
Consulting and taking that on the
airplane with me trash 80 was one of the
first laptops your first computer uh TI
portable in the late ' 80s what Texas
instrument Tas instrument oh T oh T in
in the early that's great that's great
um I had a HP 110 which was a very
primitive laptop that I used when I
worked for NPR over in the in the the
Middle East and I actually ended up
getting a portable typewriter because I
I couldn't stand having to carry the
printer around with me and when I'd show
up at these uh uh crazy War zones i'
type my stories on a typewriter and the
guys with the trash 80s and and the ti
machines would say man Hackberry has a a
computer that prints while you
type it was my last uh Victory as a lite
um so um Jenny as someone who's the CEO
of MakerBot do you stand as stride this
counterculture notion of the internet
that's typified by the whole earth
catalog and the sort of high-tech uh
sort of Gadget culture that we've been
talking about here on some level yeah I
think that the um the the desktop 3D
printing industry actually straddles
both of those lines so it really comes
out of a an open open software and open
Hardware uh culture hacker culture and
it's evolved into into something that
that is a more professional professional
model and professional way of looking at
things but at the same time is a
30-year-old technology so um it starts
it's it's very similar to the way that
the the whole uh evolution of computers
is works so 30 year 30 years ago the
first 3D printers took up big rooms and
they cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars and and now we're making a 3D
printer because of the open open
foundation because of expiring patents
that can sit on your desktop the first
3D printer wasn't made to prevent a
nuclear attack though right it was not
made to prevent a nuclear attack and
what comes out of it probably would
survive a nuclear attack really oh wow
what was it made originally to you um I
I think that I actually will have to say
I uh shame on me for not knowing what
was make something good make something
good of course of course um you recall
the building of the internet and this
sort of development of packet switching
and Imagining the system and world that
could could be created with that what
was that like sure I was a uucp
administrator and uh uh my my roots are
are in hardcore Unix so um anybody know
what hardcore Unix is out there I mean
you don't know what hardcore Unix is
UNIX is the precursor to what really
it's the operating system for the the uh
uh PDP precursor to the modern era no
pre but was Unix developed at Xerox Park
Bell at Bell at B that's right that's
yeah so um yeah I was inv I remember
when when when you know Al Gore came out
and said that he had invented the
Internet um and all of us were sitting
around going holy crap what have we been
doing all this time and this has been
around for a long time um and we've all
been using it to send all sorts of
interesting information back and forth
and um you know we thought I think that
that the same sort of thing with the 3D
printing industry happened like we felt
a little ripped off because this was our
secret and it was meant to be something
that that you could share Communications
and do cool things and and the rest of
the world didn't know about was sort of
a secret and it was also I think a cool
part about thought it was being it was
part of the defense industry so you felt
like you were you were also a part of
this this bigger thing that no one
really knew about and that if the world
blew up we'd all be able to send each
other messages and we' be able to say
hey we're still alive here what are you
doing out there and um it was a it was
sort of a secret society so it was
really interesting when it became
publicized and we decided to share it
but we still couldn't believe like so
what are you going to do with it like
what what more what more is there and
part of the story of the innovators was
how this priest Ood of Unix users in
places like Xerox Park and Bell Labs Etc
um uh get introduced to Unix and pull
aspects of the art architecture and the
style of Unix down and create some of
the products that a lot of people in
this audience know about you want to
tell a couple you know particularly
interesting about that too is that they
create an open source version of it
which is Linux right and gnu Linux which
is Richard stalman who is a total profit
of a mad man you know at MIT and
believes that all software should be
free and open sourced and whatever and
so he's creating a version of Unix or
compatibil with Unix from scratch but of
course he's a bit of a Madman so he
doesn't ever do the kernel so this guy
named lenus tvold does it out in U
Finland and um it becomes G new Linux
and it is that tension between the
proprietary software and the free and
open source software movement that I
find um that the you know there's you
may believe there's a a right answer to
that question but I almost believe the
right answer is the tension between the
two and the dynamic I I think it's an
important tension I think it's it's part
of what what still is is part of the
Innovation cycle it's funny the last
time I saw ston he had some um
interesting words to share for me um I I
used to work at MIT Tech Square and uh
he was up on the he used to go and he
had his bed in one of the offices up
there I mean he he wasn't paying for it
but anyway he had some Choice words for
me the last time he saw me
yeah he was like a lot of great
innovators a um prickley is a prickley
character what did he say you sold out
or something something oh anybody who
ever works for anything that has any
intellectual property protection at all
is in his mind well evil or something
yeah and it was right after it was right
after MakerBot had um gone from being
full Open Source Hardware full open
source software to to not quite all open
source software so he was really not
happy and it was revealed that we had
also filed some patents no can I ask you
patents you filed
Pat oh but but God I could show you my
Pat hey John can I ask you a question on
that because it's been me you filed for
patents because you're becoming a
company and you need to have some return
on your Investments and stuff and people
like stalman think that that's horrible
nobody should ever do intellectual
property uh people have often asked me
how how much Innovation would you
curtail if you didn't allow people to
own the intellectual property would you
have been curtailed if you couldn't make
money on what you were
inventing would we have would we have
not done it would you have I say
curtailed I'm not quite sure I mean
about that but I meant would you have
not done as much of it I think that if
if it's interesting the patents didn't
exist we wouldn't have actually been
where we are um so yeah I think that
again I think that's it's a virtuous
cycle and and you know it's sort of the
devil you know I mean that does a patent
system need to be revised perhaps but um
the fact that people are are filing
patents and in in essence sharing their
ideas and thinking and and thought
process Spurs a lot of innovation so uh
at the same time it protects it and
allows it to get somewhere uh and and
allows people to see where it goes so
that then they they can they can do
something else with it but are your
patents and the patent ownership that
you have the IP ownership that you have
are they a principal part of your
business business plan or proposal that
you have to take to people who finance
you or didn't you need that in other
words is that the first question they
asked got any
patents it's it's it's interesting the
3D PR printing industry is very much
steeped in IP and and IP ownership so
it's uh it's a very defensive World um
with with patents and the IP is used is
used sort of in a cold it's more of a
cold war strategy than than than not um
but it's very much a part of the culture
of the 3D printing world and when you
when you talk to almost any 3D printing
company IP and patents are are basis of
what of of any of the companies so it's
whether they're defying them or whether
or whether they're creating them but but
you would not have the innovation in the
3D printing world if it were not for
patents and and people filing their
their their their IP Katherine did you
code in Unix ever never no C++ was my
first langage plus was your first
language and do you have any patents for
your new company nope but that doesn't
mean you've sold out you you probably
CET patents and love to have it's funny
I think in what we do the community uh
the operation process there's a lot
that's um that's somewhat proprietary
but it's not patentable per seh and sort
of relates to the community social
component of the internet which is
something we'll get to in just a moment
let's do a little showand tell here um
can we see your 3D printer in action you
can see it if Josh will show show it to
us Josh baby okay this is a MakerBot
replicator uh Printing and the way that
a 3D printer works is you take a a file
that you've made in three dimension and
you put it into our software and it
slices it into tiny little slices that
are about the uh the thickness of a
piece of paper let me interrupt you for
one second call out if you can recognize
what it's making okay as it does it go
ahead keep going and then it it takes
the we we put it into the printer and it
reads the file and it takes the first
layer and it and it tells the printer to
to make it there you go there you go
well done smart group yeah yeah and it's
magic it's all about real estate in New
York you know that's all these people
talk about so it it takes it takes a
piece of plastic and brings it into
something that looks like an icing bag
and it makes the plastic hot and melty
and it squeezes it through a really tiny
hole and it lays down the image of of a
layer and then it goes up the next layer
and does that and how important is the
chemical composition of the medium you
use to create something like that
Material Science and and physics are a
big big part of what what makes the
technology work and uh this kind of
plastic is it something very exotic or
is it like what I used to do to make
those insects when I had a thing maker
it's not no it's not those no it's poly
lactic acid and it's a corn-based
product so um I like to say that when my
dogs eat it they don't
die there are any other materials that
are used with other 3D printers that are
not as friendly and there's there's a
lot of there's a very wide range of
materials like a goo and laser printer
like I also say that if you drink that
goo you would die so it's not something
that you really put on your desktop it's
not a very friendly friendly substance
so MakerBot makes 3D printers that
enables people cre people's creativity
and allows them to innovate and we like
people to be able to do that on their
desktop so we use a friendly material
that that doesn't hurt you while you do
it and and the creation of the Macintosh
was the use of friendly materials and
the ideas that people could do something
without destroying it and you know do
you have an aspiration I mean aside from
being a successful business and all of
that stuff that uh you know you've sold
out for um do you have an aspiration for
the 3D printer in terms of there should
be one in every home it should be a part
of culture in some way that it that it
that everyone would have a creative use
for this tool in their own home
we have have a mission to get a 3D
printer in every school in the country
um we would love love one in every
school in the world but we're just going
to start out with America um and there
are lots of schools in America that the
concept of getting um 3D printers into
the schools and making sure that kids
see a 3D printer as a tool that they
have to be able to solve problems with
or model model their life with or see
how math works or or bring an idea to
life um means means that once kids see a
3D printer is a tool that they take into
life then when they go to college they
need a 3D printer and when they they go
to work they better have a 3D printer
and I remember when uh you know my math
teachers in in uh High School I really
am old had slide roles and we weren't
allowed to bring calculators into class
and now like uh you know um my my
stepchildren who are in school um 12
year old it's on his list you have to
have a calculator you're in trouble if
you don't have a calculator where's your
calculator for Ma class what's wrong
with a pen and pencil but um no I I
think of my kids as cheaters so we want
3D yeah they are right they use a
calculator don't tell them but I I
certainly think of them that way but we
but we want kids to have 3D printers
because it's a tool and and and it lets
you take a virtual idea and make it
physical and and see how the world works
one of the other ideas that comes
directly out of your book is the fact
that the universality of instructions of
zeros and ones and uh packets data pack
packets means that you can specify a
physical object send those
specifications anywhere in the world and
any 3D printer anywhere in the world can
produce that object custom made to the
individual who needs it and you have an
example of that here today oh yeah um so
this is this is really one of my very
favorite projects it's the robohan
project um and it's a story between
South Africa and Seattle um where a man
had cut his fingers off uh in South
Africa and he he has a guy who makes
props in Seattle and the two of them
work across the world to create a
prosthetic um because they they want to
have a custom prosthetic and um the sort
of cool end of story is that that the
South African neighbor is a 5-year-old
who doesn't have the fingers on his hand
because he um was born without his
fingers and he makes a prosthetic for
for for Liam and uh a prosthetic for a
kid is is not very common because
Prosthetics cost thousands tens of
thousands of dollars and kids do
something unique to adults and that
their bones grow um so uh kids would
need many Prosthetics through their life
so often they don't get them and and the
cost of the robo hand is is a few
dollars probably less than $5 doar when
you put it together and this is a
collaboration where the measurements of
the disabled person's hand is then
transmitted across the internet using
the computers that Walter's described
here those specifications are fed into
the uh uh 3D printer which can instantly
make a prototype that can be almost
instantly tested and you ref find it in
a very very quick amount of time and I
behind you I think we've got I brought
one so it's I mean this is just a
rudimentary like um you one for me to
show you but um and it's not working
very well but there's one out there on
the desk that does workit better but
it's got fingers and so this is the
basic first concept so one of the a some
things about 3D printing is that it's an
iterative technology so this is the
first version of Robo hand and and this
is a a different version of it's
iterated and it's iterated for for who
you are and what you want and one of the
coolest thing that I've seen is that
because of the robo hands project I mean
about 70 we've had about 70,000
downloads from our website thing of our
so it's a free download people make them
there's a whole network of people who
will make one for you but kids are proud
of their prosthetic so not only are they
able to have a hand but they're able to
have the cool hand that they want and
it's they make them in different colors
they put hooks on them they do all these
cool things and like they are just the
coolest people around because they have
the best hand going 7 player right in
there yeah can you think sure you
probably cheat with them yeah exactly
it's my favorite project well it's great
I was at an event last week where uh a
rocket scientist who saw a video of a
little dog that didn't have two front
legs oh yeah who was rolling around in
this really badly designed velcro and
skate wheel um little wheelchair kind of
thing said I can fix that he had access
to a 3D printer he took a picture he
sent uh his prototype off that arrived
in the mail completely unexpectedly they
opened it up they tried it out they sent
back to him pictures of what it looked
like he said oh great I have to change
this I have to do that he asked them to
get a mold of the top of the Torso of
the dog they sent it back to him they
sent the uh prototype back to the dog
owner and we had it on stage of this
little dog rolling around unbel it's
great man so like it's you can make
anything you want but it's awesome when
you have stories where it this changes
kids lives this changes people's lives
you know kids who've never had a hand
they they can now pick up their school
bag they can throw a ball they can write
they can draw they can it they can be it
it completely changes their lives so
changing people's lives is awesome
there's so something so unintimidating
about it Walter you would have noticed
this immediately the expression on the
Chihuahua's face was was I kid you not
what took you so long
folks so Katherine as someone involved
in a startup right now you know we've
heard all these stories of adversity of
tension of creative tension of uh people
in garages sort of doing these brilliant
things that make them billionaires um do
you find that the mil for creating a
startup right now the venture capitalist
you have to deal with the finance years
you have to deal with the you know Wall
Street Journal uh contests that you
enter that I described at the beginning
is a nurturing environment for an
entrepreneur right now so it's funny I
actually think in some ways that it is
because anytime you're trying to create
something that never existed before
there are so many forces that tell you
you're crazy and as much as you know
there's a lot of press around startups
today and entrepreneurs you still run
into the exact same barriers you run
into the people who think you're insane
to leave your job job the employees who
don't want to quit well-paying positions
to come take terrible pay at your
company because you can't offer anything
less um the the the big competitors the
running out of money and while there is
a you know a little bit of froth right
now I'm not necessarily saying that
that's ideal I think having the
community around makers and Builders is
incredibly helpful you love your team uh
absolutely I mean I think one of the
things you have to do if you're building
a company is is find the people who will
take this crazy Leap of Faith with you
um and and go on a journey where they
are trusting you in themselves that
you're going to end up at something that
makes the previous how many of years is
worthwhile describe what we're seeing
here and describe as much as you can
your uh product and what about it that
proprietary and utilizes some of the
precise uh phenomena that we've been
discussing here yeah so this is a a page
from The Muse uh the muse.com is my
company and we essentially exist to help
people particularly people in the first
10 to 15 years of their career figure
out what they want to do with their
lives and how to get there so we have
about a 100,000 people every day that
are coming to the website this is one of
the personalized homepages where users
can tell us where they are in their
career whether they want help
negotiating a raise getting a promotion
um dealing with a difficult boss finding
a new job and then we will based on what
they tell us about what they're looking
for and where they are we will help
direct them to companies to
Opportunities and to Career advice and
other resources is this algorithmically
driven or is it a bank of of phone
callers in Bangalore so it is
uh there's no uh there's no uh phone
callers in Bangalore um we have a number
of algorithms that are proprietary to
the Muse and it's interesting because
we're also collecting a lot of data that
we're not using yet I think some of the
most interesting things about what we're
doing are yet to come because we're
tracking for Millions I think we've had
well over 20 million people used the
site so far and we know you know people
who like this sort of career path um
often behave in in interesting or
unexpected ways I think one of one of my
personal passions is is is how people
decide what they're going to do
professionally because there's so many
options today and I think a lot of
people have Choice paralysis and it's
interesting to start to see patterns
emerge that aren't the classic linear
path and yet um turn out to be very good
predictors of where people started and
how they can end up in a career that
they're excited uh and care about how
much data capture is a part of your uh
your business it's a very large part um
what's interesting though is we haven't
um we haven't gated the site so people
can come uh in off the internet use most
of what we do and leave without ever
giving us identifying information that
is a a bit of a catch 22 right now
because you know our data would be even
better if we told people welcome to the
Muse in order to use anything that we do
you have to sign in um and we've made
the um sort of not moral decision but
the the the decision that what we we we
want this to be open um it does limit a
little bit how much we can follow and
track but there's that tension again how
valuable do you think her data would be
as someone who well it's huge and you
know that's one of the things that Lord
Byron would warn us about which is
making sure our moral sensibilities keep
up with our technological advances
whether it's the NSA or corporations
that collect all of our data that's why
we have to understand technology and
wrestle with and I these can be good or
bad things I'm not um you
know you prozer on either side but if
you don't understand your technology and
you don't understand what uh information
other people have about you uh it's hard
to figure out this privacy versus
convenience or privacy versus security
balances that we all have to make as
Citizens and the media needs to
encourage precisely this curiosity stay
curious it's so important would would uh
uh Walter would AA have a 3D printer and
would AA love Katherine's uh I'll put it
in you know to some historic context
both these things are so cool to me in
terms of the history especially American
history I'll not put Ada in right away
but there are two distinct strands I
think in the American character which
you can read toille on one is our maker
culture character the quilting bees and
barn raisings and everything else there
is a do-it-yourself strand that you can
start with the Boston Commons almost and
see that and that's what you represent
is the maker culture in America and
maker fairs but maker fairs are not new
they've been around for 300 years so
that is something that's being enabled
after I think a period of maybe half a
century in which the ability to make
things was taken away from us generally
and they were Mass produc used this
allows a do-it-yourself culture that
Stuart brand was uh celebrating in the
whole earth catalog the other great
strand in the history of technology and
the history of America uh I sometimes
quote Bruce Sterling in one of his
sci-fi stories says the street Finds Its
Own uses for things and one of the
things that we find our own uses for of
any technology is to form community and
to make connection you did that when you
on the I don't know you said you unet in
the used group and you grab the internet
for something it wasn't really designed
to be which was a community formation
thing and email becomes it and bulletin
boards and whatever likewise your um
service is simply a way to say let us
form communities and those two strands
interweave interestingly because the
do-it-yourself culture in America is
actually a doit ourselves culture in
which people love to get get together
and sort of do a barn raising together
or a quilting be together or a uh maker
Fair together so uh it's a cool strand
in well it our character it's also you
know it argues against the notion and I
think often times you see on financial
channels and in the media this idea that
if we broke open the head of Steve Jobs
there would be some magical sort of
Elixir some sort of formula that the
Innovation resides in individual people
what did Gates do what did Warren
Buffett do what did and in fact The
Innovation culture in America is enabled
by this Collective sense of doing the
innovators is us and uh that piece of it
is so brilliant and wonderful and well
uh portrayed in in this book here and
it's the connections between all of the
people you kind of want to get them all
on the same bus and have a party with
them at the end of the book it's really
so great K's
uh on the bus or off the bus I think uh
Bill Gates on acid would be a very
interesting movie do you know I I I'm s
i to do but Steve Jobs's line on that
what uh when he was asked about Bill
Gates and he said if Bill Gates had just
dropped acid once or joined in ashram in
India he would be more
creative Steve was not the president of
the Bill Gates fan club but they
actually did like it yeah yeah yeah so
uh I want to thank all of you for being
here I want to thank Catherine and Jenny
for being here
um Walter wow Walter will be at this
yeah yeah yeah I have an Oculus here
Walter will be signing books out in the
lobby I just want to let you all know it
is my 19th anniversary uh today and my
wife and
I are going off to a hotel in the
Andromeda
galaxy to have a very wild time tonight
I'm John huckberry thank you very much
good
[Music]
[Applause]
night